foreign
dioxide
um so we keep blaming
this little guy here and you know what
it's not to be playing because actually
greenhouse gases in general are good for
the planet this is what keep our planet
warm enough for us to survive it's like
a little blanket keeping a little bit of
The Hitting so we're here and we're
happy however when you have a bit too
much of it it's a bit like today I don't
know you guys but we all left the house
with really heavy coats because the
summer wasn't expected to be back today
oh it's a bit of the same if you have a
bit too much of it you just overdoing it
and that's what's happening the excess
greenhouses Patrick has a carbon dioxide
is what's causing global warming and
global warming in turn causes climate
change
so what we're trying to vote to do is
try to avoid releasing so much
greenhouses so that blanket remains
healthy and our planet remains safe the
problem is of course that as we heard
before
if you don't keep that warming swap 1.5
degrees and remember any warming is bad
because it's getting us out of balance
but 1.5 degrees is what the scientists
worked out today is kind of a safe we
can just about manage the consequences
now I want to cop to represents
nottingen and when I came back a lot of
people asking did cop do anything or Top
Cop 26 that's the United Nations
um climate change conference last
November
and I said well you know prior to cop if
the scientists worked out that all the
pledges that everyone signed up for in
the Paris agreement 2015. four of them
were met
then we were heading for global warming
of 2.1 degrees
after cop we heading to a 1.8 degrees of
warming now any degree of warming is bad
and 1.8 is lower than 2.1 so actually
it's successful but I must repeat this
all the pleads must be met in full and
on time for us to just manage that
degree of warming
and let's just face it humans have been
very good at meeting other plants not on
time not ever fully ever at all
um and of course we're running out of
time in order to get there this is
really important we all engage with this
and it's a really big task for everyone
so I always I start all my lectures
every year showing a slide that says
panic
because what I really want you to do is
also Panic with me
I know I have a bigger road to playing
Center I'm teaching a lot of students
but also part of my role is to get you
to panic a little bit so you do a little
bit too a little bit by little bit we
can get there
so I I live in Nottingham I'm originally
from Brazil I've been watching for
almost 20 years notching has pledged to
be carbon neutral by 2028 the first city
in the UK the first one to pledge and
the first one is trying to get to that
Target that's really quite big I've read
this week that kompehagen has just
dropped the carbon neutrality targets
because they couldn't get funding for a
particular big part of it and they were
meant to be the first one in Europe I
think so it might be the nothing in this
if it's not the first in Europe if it
does achieve it is quite close now it's
not an easy task consumers imagine a
whole city is covered emissions
everything we do at all times release
relieves carbon being here today
transporting all the stands here
yourself to the site or the food we're
eating everything releases carbon so
it's a really big task notching has
managed so far to get it down by 57.7
0.7 for inhabitant and that's one of the
largest drops in the whole of Europe so
that's really good news and but also a
lot of the really big wins have been won
so we're getting down to the hardest
bits to Taco and that's what becomes a
lot more difficult
now I work at studying the beauty
environment transport energy in how
people relate to those why it is
important it is Task so the yellow bit
is what Econo economically is easy
enough for low-cost things we could
tackle so the beauty environment you can
see you can reduce the emission quite
significantly in relatively low cost way
it's not low cost for you or me because
you guys are going to see I'm going to
tell you a bit more about your own home
but relatively to the governments and to
the leaders across the world is a much
cheaper way to deal with carbon
emissions than some of the other issues
now we add an event of nothing in the
group that I work on with my colleagues
I attend I saw you I'm gonna make up
some words now but I'm I'm from Brazil
so I'm you know English is not my first
language I'm allowed so I've tried to
divide our work in three sections we say
we um we look into Electrify you
probably heard a lot of politification
why because we're trying to decarbonize
our energy greed so the more renewable
we have into the an electricity grid the
less carbon we have released from the
energy so if you can make everything
that we use electric we could tend to
reduce our carbon and then in particular
it's transport so you might be looking
at purchasing your electric vehicle if
you are to purchase a vehicle next and
heating from building so that the two
big things that we're gonna let me find
the next few years I also talk about
rationalizing and that's the most
important of the first step I reduce
what we're using the first place
electrifying and reduce the carbon
missions from the grid is not going to
do the whole job so it really do needs
to start using a lot less
and then it's mattifying it
um which you understand what it means
although it's made up but I do mean you
know trying to understand where the
energy flows out why is the data try to
be able to control things with a more a
higher level granularity try to take
away some of the decisions from some
people for example you want to plug your
car and you want your car to do the best
for the for the environment as well save
your money as opposed to having to
decide on all those things so these
modification is a great way to move
forward
I'm going to show you a few examples of
our research where under those three and
three handles of course the intercept
and interlap but you get an idea so um
give you the example of Nottingham while
rationalize is so important and how far
you can get us nothing has about 6 164
000 homes
now have you heard of financial
performance certificate
so maybe if you rent a home or if you've
recently purchased a home you might have
had to have it analyzed and checked for
its energy performance so that's a
little it's like a check box exercise
for a little bit of maths that gives you
a rating and it's very much like your
the rating they get from my appliances
so from green to Red we should all be
buying green but we don't often do that
when we purchase properties although
very unlikely going to go and purchase a
fridge that is red
I don't know why but we still think the
beauty is okay a lot
but anyway the government's proposing
their own homes in the whole UK have to
be at least an EPC level of C I be
within the green zone by 2030 which is
very soon I'm sure you agree in not
singer that would be 61 percent of the
homes that have to move from Orange and
reds into green within the next few
years
and that's very similar to the rest of
England so most likely where you are but
if you know the neighborhood even worse
newer neighborhood perhaps a bit better
but on the average we are about the same
about 60 of the homes need to be
improved to that level
a home that is about an EPC level an
average of D which is the average that
we have in the UK at the moment I
released about six stones of carbon per
year so per home as a lot of carbon
now let's assume that we did get to them
get them all to EPC level C now I live
in an old Victorian house in a
conservation Zone if you are with me
conservation Zone old houses is a really
tough job I can't afford changing my
windows because I can't change them for
anything that is Affordable in any way
it needs to be Windows there it will
accept when a conservation Zone replace
like for like but with double glazing
ideally super glazing I can't put an
insulation on my walls internal or
external so it's a really tough job to
get to PC level C and quite unlikely we
can get there but let's assume I can and
you can too and now your homes get to
this level C and you're healthier and
spending less money and I'm sure you're
thinking how that would be good if
you've seen your energy bills this week
this month
um
yeah I think that's the time it's gonna
hit everyone isn't it when you see
you're hitting going on in October and
your gas bill comes next
well so if we did get them all to PC
level see the they will be releasing
about 4.5 tons of carbon per home in
Nottingham that would lead us to a
reduction of
247 000 tons of carbon which still
leaves us with 740 000 tons of carbon
for the existing house stock alone
per year and of course there's a lot of
new homes being built what does that
mean well there's equivalent about 740
000 Hotel balloons every year or they
have equivalent of 10 000 10 times the
area of the city of Nottingham in trees
so we cannot offset offset is just not
an option because even here they were
talking about how the home is becoming
much better we still have such a
enormous amount of upsetting to do that
just there's no room
for everybody
so I need to do better
now those 4.5 tones of carbon if you
look into this so let's assume your
house is all got to that level
42 of that to becoming foam Heating in
average
now if we Electrify Heating and we can
then tap into an electricity grid that
is decarbonized you're likely to get
those 42 carbon emissions diminished
show even disappearing which is great
but that's just about half of the
problem isn't it
the other half is your choice of travel
your choice of food the way you manage
your waste it's not one big win it's
lots and lots of really little wins and
then when it gets really complicated
because you leave the light on and think
it's fine it's just one LED that's been
on and indeed One LED that's been on for
a couple of hours is a tiny amount of
finishing a tiny amount of carbon also a
tiny amount of money but if all of us
left one lady on for a couple of hours
every day just because it's fine then
all together there's a lot of cabin
and it does seem quite small but it's
only one note those small things are put
together that we're gonna do after 50 of
the problem
so one of the problems I've been looking
at is looking at a road map for
retrofitting audience to look at all
those housing stock there's a lot to
this pressure but I want to store a few
bits and pieces for you to have a feel
for it it's funded by the government it
is um
it's funded to the Community Renewal
fund it's a leveling up fund agenda that
has come out last year so it's kind of a
one-off fund the government had nothing
I had four projects funded this is one
of them
uh residential buildings are present at
least 22 percent of government in the UK
If that's considering the uh your choice
of transport and Saturday talking with
doubling that up eighty percent of those
are still really bad you still need
Improvement so if we look at uh what
that really means so this is really
recent so that's where you're likely
spending your money in your energy bills
I think it just came out last month it's
for more often and you can see the Big
Blob there is central heating and
central heating being on for six hours a
day I don't know how long you left your
own hopefully nobody has the central
heating on yet so you spend about almost
10 pounds for six hours of heating at
the moment and it might still go up
again next year because we don't know
what's going to go on I think
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas